what's happening reject nation so as
many of you probably know we went to the
spider-man no way home premiere all
thanks to koi zhandro uh everyone we met
was all thanks to him and uh he got a
chance to interview terry crews and i
was going to put it in that spot my no
way home premiere video but i was like
come on we covered brooklyn nine nine
once a week i'm gonna slap it off at the
beginning of here if you're really not
interested you can go ahead and skip it
but i think it's a total blast and uh
yeah especially uh just you can watch
them how you've been man
yeah
his son recognized me is isn't that
awesome
yeah he said real reject
family reunions on the red carpet how
it's done the magic this is spider-man
the biggest movie of the year it's all
going crazy all happening i know you
guys both love your superhero stuff what
are you most excited about about this
one first of all the multiverse the
potential of the multiverse man the fact
that you know what this is the thing man
it's rewriting the rules of film itself
you understand what i mean where you can
go and jump franchises anything's
possible anything is possible it's your
expendables it's all coming back to a
whole nother level right exactly and man
one thing that blows my mind
that it's you know it's really opened up
all the things that you you always
dreamed of when i was a kid i used to
sit there and talk to my friends man
what if they ever made an x-men movie
what if they ever made a and we used to
think about this stuff but the fact that
it's happening yeah man i never thought
i would see it i really didn't so
multiversal any franchise you could
bring back from the past and fold into
the present say there's an 80s remake
that's coming back say you got your 21
jump street you bring in johnny depp
what is your childhood franchise you
want to fold into the present with a
franchise first of all what i would do
is take it horror wise
i would i would take the franchise the
thing
and mix it with aliens
oh i love that and bring that together
can you imagine
the creature from the thing
touches the xenomorph from alien
dude all in i was a billion dollars you
already sold a billion dollars
so we got a sinister six theoretically
form in here and you guys know you're
spider-man bad guys who that we haven't
seen yet do you want to see most
oh nobody teased or not
anybody hmm we haven't seen you haven't
seen yet brand new your head cannon
probably hobgoblin yeah do you want us
to be ned do you want it to be our jacob
madeline i want it to be ned actually
yeah you want to see him go how do you
want him to break bad
[Music]
money questions
oh man the writers are right here he'll
just go crazy man i don't know he'll
just
he'll just lose his sanity so i'm
thinking like maybe he tries to save mj
instead of him and that sees him snap
he's like my best friend didn't try to
save me hobgoblin
yep that's kind of hot that's what i do
that's what i do so the end of the year
is kind of wrapping up we've got this
and then we got matrix next week
everything feels like it's coming back
what are you guys most anticipating for
like movies to get into the rhythm of
what did you miss most in the pandemic
wow man you know what though i i i have
to say actually streaming helped me so
much
because again because it filled that
that gap because i could get we could
get more in depth you know what i'm
saying and it was so wild because the
scarlet witch became like that whole
series
blew my mind man i mean when i
and when i when i look at what they're
doing just on disney plus every
character you can spend 10 episodes with
i'm investing love them
and but you also got to think when like
guardians of the galaxy was a comic book
that was just off to the side it wasn't
really popular a lot like blade was
right when that is the reason we all got
this the blade is the reason we're here
right now
what i'm really excited for is the
things they can dig out of the dust out
of the desk
and things that we haven't seen and
characters that we don't know
that we can really expose who's your
deep cut you want to see most oh
man i mean there was a character this is
you may not know
a lot of people may not know about but i
love that it was a robot from space
named rob
rob if you look him up i'm telling you
it was crazy because he landed and he
was killing people
and this isn't a marvel comic book
marvel the whole thing but what they
were were people they were aliens
masquerading as people
so but the violence was off the charts
yeah and people were like no like i
remember reading a book like he's
killing people
but rom was really just getting red
he was like shyamalan twist
it was a twist on the terminator look it
up all right it's a really that's new to
me i'm invested
oh i do remember that wrong i just had
to see it in my head all right last two
questions for you i know you're both
fitness-based individuals you got three
spider-man who do you think had the best
spidey physique of andrew toby tom ooh
probably
i'm gonna dress up i really
andrew is handsome
but i think tom and tom tom is he's got
that ballerina core right he's got like
he looks like he can actually you know
what i mean yeah he's a dance we're
going tom and then out of all the marvel
comics what superhero would you want to
train with what do you want to have an
hour in the gym with wolverine
wolverine
oh my god infinite power infinite reps
infinite reps oh my god dude just get
him angry and we go all day all right
that's the best answer i appreciate it
thank you so much man dude i used to
wear this i see you all the time
i'm over here yeah dude so like before
the before time so i was like wait a
second i know i like this better i like
this side better this is just the better
spot yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] love
brooklyn
[Music]
guys
captain holt has no pants on at 11 55
a.m captain holt walked past us holding
a hot bowl of soup at 12 03 p.m i heard
him yell out
she entered holding nothing one minute
later she left holding an opaque bag
captain holt's pants were in that bag
his knees are in the breeze
that evidence is circumstantial so you
guys want visual confirmation not really
done
hey captain oh no something at my desk
real quick just leave it on the couch
okay
sir
you're gonna freak yo yo ma is in the
precinct and he's giving out
i got a losses i'm gonna die
i got you jake no no no
i swallowed it i blowed it it's fine
i made you another bowl of soup since
you spilled yours earlier you're gonna
have to come over here to get it i'm
sick of you wasting time so yes i spill
some minestrone into my pants and i'm
sitting in my underwear happy yes
[Music]
i need you to sign off on look at us
just three people with pants on having
no story here [ __ ] you're all a
bunch of liars
there's so much
no pants action happening dog party 15.
big shout out to charles boyle we should
really thank my ex-wife we split it in
the divorce i get it for december
through february winter bee house woof
woof yeah it's not really catching on
dog party 15.
[Applause]
oh no
is this gonna be the weekend we finally
meet six drink amy one drink amy's a
little spacey
wait what two drinks loud amy you want
to get a cab
five drink amy is weirdly confident
let's do this little man
[Laughter]
scene sixth drink amy maybe she's the
one i could actually be friends with aka
my sasquatch ah i think we'll see it oh
oh oh i know you lost your phone charger
so i got you a new one for some sweet
long distance texting thanks oh no you
got to say this thank you i said thank
you that was the first thing i said
i'll text you inappropriate work kids
too fast can't stop him
oh
rosa d knocking down with her boo on the
street cebu again i will shoot you in
the stomach love a boy it is what did i
just say what did i just say
[Laughter]
i'm sure you'll have a hoot oh yeah
although i'm sure our hoot's pale in
comparison to the hoots that you had
back in the day i wasn't privy to those
events as a gay black detective i was
excluded from most social gatherings you
guys off to play some golf yeah you want
a caddy
no i've always wanted to josh around
with my peers so you've never joshed
around with anyone
never go have fun with the squad really
josh around for me invite him come on
dude eleanor told me to keep the place
clean but i don't care mommy's out of
town and we're gonna party you call your
ex-wife mommy not consciously
i am prepared for any vacation situation
i've got a bottle opener sunscreen
inflatable neck pillow wait are we
having
fondue
you ready to party or what i don't mind
if i oh
what whoa
[Music]
already what up party people
he brought him
now i'm always saying it ain't a real
party till your boss shows up
unexpectedly hello
[Laughter]
oh yes
no party like a captain whole party
cause the captain holt party is a total
surprise to everyone
i would [ __ ] hate that so much
what the hell jake look he told me this
story about how his squad always
excluded him i felt bad you would have
too
what's to josh around is that so bad i
am dating his nephew now we're hanging
out on weekends what is next oh
small talk
you got to be glad that holt's here
right i mean you're basically in love
with him i love him i'm definitely not
comfortable being drunk around him james
please keep the volume down okay sorry
it's two drinks i can't help it that's
it i'm cutting myself off so jake messes
up and you punish me for it
terry's our boss and he comes with us
every year correction you bring vacation
terry and he is no man's ball when the
slippers are filled
terry is chill
nice i'm texting marcus that's the most
intimate thing you can do
other than washing their hair ah yeah
what was his initial text can't believe
i missed you this much after three hours
xo where's your right back ha ha lame
you think he's mad i bet he's
heartbroken
this is stupid oh you know what we can
do after lunch walk on the beach but
it's the middle of winter which is ideal
no crowds the sand doesn't get
everywhere cause it's basically frozen
who brought their beach boots i did spot
on rosa impression
[Laughter]
i mean the wind is unexpected it's like
a thousand little needles of happiness
shooting into your face well we've been
walking for about 20 minutes so so we
should probably turn around and another
20. oh my god gina's wolf has an
80-minute walk on the beach
fiery dance moves aren't keeping me warm
mini cognac ladies oh yeah
you little bastard oh four drink amy
thank you terry's fanny and thank you
poseidon
great god of the street
[Laughter]
finally relaxing as a squad together in
the tub i can't hear anyone can we
please turn off the jets yeah
oh oh my god no more disturbed water
[Laughter]
more
uh
what
captain i bet you used to smoke cigars
on the job all the time right now no but
i had a partner did dan hammer that name
is so cool it doesn't need a nickname
nobody had one
today guys
when he died
he stuck out his middle finger so he'd
be flipping everyone off at his funeral
that is a good story who killed him
don't say a white tiger on cocaine
because i will lose it no cancer of the
mouth tongue lip and cheek
still the middle finger thing is cool
actually no one got to see that it was
closed casket because the doctors had
removed so much of his face all right
that's that
it's weird having the captain should we
just go home what do you think terry
i am not going anywhere i'm playing
crazy cupcakes i'm hydrated as hell i've
got my own party going out nice
we'll have two party he doesn't even
have to know about it separate parties
separate but equal forget i said that
phrase
here's the plan the boring halt party
will be in the living room at least
three of us must be with him in that
room at all times i think this is gonna
work and who knows maybe the hulk party
will even be fun now the recorder is
generally thought of as a training
instrument for children but
in the hands of an expert like joram
leithroom
[Laughter]
breathtaking first shift is done all
right boyle rosa and amy you're up come
on get on it and under it bangarang
drink number five you
are a true friend and a hot little piece
his name is
blair underwood the man that's on the
grocery store
it's time
for
what detective santiago you to give me a
promotion and a 40 raise
[Music]
and my back's getting tired yeah excuse
me captain
i don't think overconfident amy is
working out maybe you should go back
downstairs maybe i should just have
another drink get ready america here
comes slicks
oh no
if we're gonna pull this off we need to
focus you want to play yeah i want to
play it's quarters what am i a monster
terry tag me in you're on hult party
dude no no i know they say it's not good
to have a tv in the bedroom which is why
i don't
[Laughter]
amy and hitchcock are still upstairs i
think we're still good extreme
amy
so alone oh no oh
you're having a party without me captain
no need to explain
oh
i heard him my fanny's not deep enough
to fix this vacation terry
is dead
i invited him up here i should go talk
to him okay really thought you were
gonna fight me on that no it's
uncomfortable i'd much rather you do it
here i go
hey i need to write marcus back fast i
really like him i don't want to screw
this crap up that's what you should say
yeah yeah i sent it he didn't write back
so he hates it
it's happening
it's a shirtless pick i'm gonna leave
don't follow me things are about to get
intense that makes sense
sheeps
you got to see the sasquatch was it
everything you dreamt it was the stuff
drums are made of now drink this entire
glass of water you're taking care of me
just because i know you won't remember
it
six drink amy is your friend
really hate those jets huh i'm not a
child i don't need a bubble bath
before you say anything i want to say
i'm sorry i forgot this getaway is
really for you detectives and one of the
things you're striving to get away from
is your captain everyone loves you
but you're our captain i think instead
of us rising to your level it's maybe
time for you to stoop down to heart
bubble bath
and
that's just a start
all the game real ray or fake ray and
joining us is a very special contestant
captain ray holt himself if he's passed
out
here's how the game works i will say a
phrase you tell me if i made it up or if
it's something that captain holt
actually said in real life i understand
the logic of this game great
the futility of lighting candles only to
blow them out immediately is just one
reason i find children's birthday
parties impractical
i don't remember saying it so it must be
fake it was real
harry's kids at their birthday party
phrase number two any smile that lasts
longer than a second and a half is a con
man's ruse i said it
and i meant it
there you go
oh there you go joshing around that's
tough
mm-hmm i hate that that's why john and i
don't have fun anymore that's why i
can't invite you to party
oh my god
you're gonna get really serious
[Laughter]
stoop to my level it's tough man i get
it dude don't worry
don't worry man don't worry we'll invite
you to the next one me and the prepper
boys
and coy
and aaron
and uh tara erickson
and uh
that's about it not as many people
to lay off some folks yeah yeah yeah
maybe a couple of the people who show up
to cinemark screenings
yeah it'll be good they get paid in
popcorn and drinks in a free movie yeah
that's true they're not really on the
payroll
that's a tough position to be in man i
know
there it is i've been there
i used to do cocaine at the hot dog
store dude it's the perfect shape to do
a rail off of
well i think a com it is a common
bonding thing is you uh
you
when you're like together you make fun
over insult or usually complain
you complain about the boss
it's a it's a common
attribute and it usually creates some
weird form of commonality with your
co-workers and stuff is bitching about
the way you're being treated as
employees
so i understand it
but
you know
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying yeah you
guys going to see what i'm saying speak
it carrying this conversation speak the
truth and i hear you exactly man [ __ ]
i'm killing this talk right yeah i think
i'm doing a great job
but
man what are you gonna do huh yeah you
know he struggled me as the kind of guy
who probably had like former jobs where
you
really got along with the boss
yeah i mean
my my employments have all been in such
a way that
yeah pretty much i mean at the coffee
house it's like i knew that guy before i
started working there at plum house and
fangirl you know i knew them yeah before
i started working there were already
about horror nights horror nights i mean
i knew jeff universal you you end up
bitching about jeff universe about
universal and and in later days comcast
uh more so
i was always blessed with very uh nice
and and uh very
uh you know what good to work with
direct supervisors so like my bosses i
didn't really have many complaints about
but uh right you know the the company
that we are all subject to
uh yeah absolutely
respect
respect 100 yeah
yeah yeah
but this was fun mm-hmm i think i just
love awkwardness so much yeah
i love
like them being uncomfortable it really
had me going to with the whole when he
got to the point
of um
you know you're rolling up your sleeves
right where the mic is pointed john
i just gotta say it's really makes for
distracting audio
you're just like
mike's right here guys you see this see
me it's directional he's just like
let me get make sure this is this is all
on camera ready
and if anybody's making a short film you
can use this as foley
there you go draped it
ah this is prop comedy yes they call
that it's prop comedy
and now i can write this shirt off
it's a work
tool yeah the um oh my goodness my eyes
are open okay so oh here's her still i
think we should do i think i'd open my
eyes should be the first review we do
with our eyes closed yes i've done that
on audio podcast sometimes i've guessed
on an audio podcast i'm so tired i'm
like if i just close my eyes and do this
i'm good
i'm like guess they got someone else's
clothes
um
yeah but like when he had the whole
thing with his partner being like that
was ultimate badass i was like oh this
is when the party turns this is the
turning point
but uh it can be awkward hell even
there's times where john and i are
together all the time or i'm like
come on man we can go to a different
part we don't we don't have to be at the
same party right now do it yeah
come on we're just teacher all the time
that's right yeah
it's a little bit like
is it a break if we're still together
is it possible to take a break in unison
come on man
let's not do this right now we spent six
days out of most every week together
occasionally seven days a week together
so and then hell depends on how that
week's going
and and i we are both the studio
is the way it goes
it can't feel that way
um especially if i'm having something
here
too yeah where i'm like get out of the
office truck stop stop
turtle leave the laptop would you i'm
going to have a party
and i want you to go and do something
only you want to do
go have fun by yourself
and be out of this office
uh
yeah he can i can be that way but these
characters
dealing with that that is a very that's
a really good workplace environment idea
i love a good beach house getaway oh
those are the best oh this made me
hungry for a for a vacay one time i took
money out of john's check
went to the beach house invited all my
closest friends
and somehow i wound up in dead open
and take out enough
just like what can i blame on john to
justify this and some money
now we uh
we've done that we're doing beach house
thing i feel like i've had a beach house
like an airbnb didn't we do a party yeah
we did a thing once when we rented an
airbnb
that was a blast
yeah
are you cold watching on the beach i
love cold walks on the beach i don't
know what they're bitching about yeah
man it's still just good shots you don't
want to go to the beach yeah
just want to look at it from the window
and know that it's there
like i like the serenity and the
i think a beach is just such a great
sensory experience of nature because
you're you're feeling like especially
like you get the air
and your nostrils with the scent it's
nice and then of course like the the
touch of the the weather on your skin
auditory of the
hearing the ocean waves it's such a
great sensory experience and i think it
like automatically helps provide what's
that type of meditative process called
is it called earthing grounding actually
that's called grounding sounds is that
where people like stepping grass they're
barefooted and stuff and i feel like the
beach does that except it's a little bit
harder access because you gotta like
drive and park yeah yeah i mean anytime
you ex go into a natural environment to
some kind of immersive degree if you're
you know like taking a walk in the woods
or you're out at the beach especially
the beach i feel like it's easy to feel
just the majesty of like this is a huge
in its own way organism that's way
bigger than me that's just naturally
occurring always that is yeah it takes
you out of you know your your petty
human squabbles of your mind and your
day and yeah then you can just behold
and then nick cannon showed up and nick
cannon was here
didn't do anything
he had a scene i'm like oh we're getting
a character maybe his
level of affection is going to be too
much for rosa to handle
and it all happened off-screen
but he really sent the texts
yes behind the scenes he's like i gotta
improvise this yeah we're gonna get some
real
[ __ ] here
what's the point of casting it but you
better do something significant i'd be
able to do something significant i feel
like he will at some point although here
now in this moment part of me is just
like i i want that to be the gag now is
he he shows up
does not much
and then exists as a character
off-screen via rose's interactions with
charles
well i i also like um
the idea of andre brauer being here it's
a tough position uh you know when
especially if you're in a leadership
environment for the group of people
you
you want to be you want to know that
when you it's time to like call some
shots you know you want to be taken
seriously
and you don't want to be like the office
clown and i think that's what made like
michael scott of the office so funny
because he could never be bothered yeah
he couldn't succeed at being the funny
guy at the office and he couldn't be
taken seriously when being a boss you
know because you were trying to be both
and so you could land yourself in that
position and i i like i just like the
concept of this episode a lot yeah and
it's just so it is very uncomfortable
like how do i just be myself without how
i behave being judged later when i'm at
the workplace environment it's a very
real
real thing to associate with and i think
that's why christian harloff doesn't
show up in any showdown things outside
of
i mean that's not a bad call you can't
get crunk the same way everybody else
must yeah it's tough
road's uncomfortable boyle awkwardly
helping out and uh
i like relaxing terry oh dude vacation
terry is a is a vibe we should all
aspire to when relaxing he was so nice
to me so far i told him i said to him uh
i uh like i love brooklyn nine-nine
and he it is surreal seeing him in
person yeah
absolutely he he looks exactly like he
does on screen like he's not as an aged
date there's an age today and he's like
just he's he's like the exact dimensions
you would imagine in real life there's
no like oh man terry's really short
you know
yeah and then you just you you just want
to riff with him yeah he's got that
energy well we didn't talk about much of
anything but we're ending this video now
uh i subscribed clicked that bell we
liked the episode it was really funny it
was good and it was a good central
conundrum i very much understand why
peralta was like hey come with us it was
their first episode to go out of typical
locations as the primary like out of a
set you know like they really shot they
obviously had to shoot on location at a
actual like rented beach house maybe
some stuff was a set like the downstairs
but they had to definitely shoot on set
and go to an actual beach location you
know which i'm sure was refreshing yeah
for them to do feels like a little
getaway and to not actually have to do
any cop stuff this time yeah exactly so
i think there was a lot of uh i i do
like when they go out it's it's more
distracting when it's like a when
there's a laugh track and they do that
yeah yeah because then you're you're
like they're just drawing on the artist
yeah yeah yeah i bring them all out here
yeah but when it's uh when it's
something like a show like this single
camera it makes it much easier to just
buy it and roll it so yeah
but guys what'd you think leave your
thoughts down below
we'll catch you guys soon
take a nap everyone take naps sleep
[Music]